that's disgusting i don't understand um
that one at all there's a lot of things
in this country um that i don't
understand that we're looking at right
now as a continuous set it's about us to
educate ourselves about us getting
registered to vote on going out there
and doing that and making sure that
we're educated on who we're voting for
and um what they're going to do while
they're in office uh so i mean that's
that's one of the biggest things that
i'd say we've taken a step as a team is
trying to just talk about talk about
that the importance to vote and the
importance to uh for our voices to be
heard throughout our communities and be
leaders there but that's simply
unacceptable and don't understand
an officer not being charged in that
case
that's dak prescott cowboys quarterback
yesterday meeting with reporters talking
about the decision to not charge any of
the officers involved in the shooting
death of brianna taylor in louisville
earlier this year
and you know peter when i see
that when i hear that i think boy it
wasn't that long ago
that the question wouldn't be asked and
the answer wouldn't be given and it's
amazing how far we've come we're at the
point where it's natural to ask the
question it's natural to give a real
answer and it's natural to not care if
there's a segment of the audience that
hears it and disagrees and gets mad and
huffs and puffs and may or may not blow
someone's house down
well i remember at the start of the
season when people were looking at
anecdotal television ratings evidence
and saying see people don't want
athletes to be talking about this crap
they just don't and they're going to
vote with their feet basically in their
eyes and they're not going to turn on
the games
well
as i said at the time i said to me it's
just that's a lie
it's an absolute lie
because people will watch football
people like football they can
compartmentalize their anger over no
matter how far to the right left middle
wherever they are
they know that
now that athletes are going to speak up
and say what they feel just like lebron
james did last night in the middle of
the game there's an adidas commercial
and patrick mahomes is talking about
you know all of the social ills in our
society so these guys are not going to
shut up anymore and i say
good for them
and i do believe that at the end of the
year i don't know what the ratings are
going to be
we saw the last time
in an election year that the ratings
cratered for a while because everybody
was so intensely interested in the
election in 2016
who knows what the ratings will be this
year i don't know but
to to think that
john doe in plano texas
is going to say well that's it i'm not
watching cowboys seahawks sunday because
my quarterback is talking about brianna
taylor i mean
you know first of all
that's that's not going to happen number
one and number two it might happen very
very
uh
in a very scattered way but i don't
believe it's going to happen to to do
something like crater the television
ratings
and it's amazing to see the dog
whistling of racism that happens in
situations like this and i know there's
going to be people who get mad just
because i've even uttered that phrase
but here's the reality anytime one of
these incidents happen the reaction by
some
is predictable they're going to view the
facts and the light most favorable to
the police officer and the light most
unfavorable to the black person who was
killed and let's just ponder for a
second what happened to brianna taylor
and let's just ask ourselves whether
this entire concept of no knock warrants
needs to go out the window because if
it's any of the people out there
defending what happened to brianna
taylor put yourself
in that situation you're in bed
you have guns in your house because you
fully and completely support the second
amendment and you also know that you
have the right to shoot and kill anyone
who breaks into your house
well the no knock warrant
authorizes police to break into your
house without announcing who they are so
if you're home and you're in bed and
someone's breaking into your house
you're going to shoot first and you're
going to ask questions later and the
problem is in that situation the shot
first came from the person who was in
his house that was getting broken into
and then a cascade of bullets entered
from the police officers who didn't
identify themselves in advance that's it
it's that simple
and you know people want to try to other
side everything look it's just it's it's
a defect in the legal system
that needs to be addressed uh
independent of whether to what extent
the police officers behave properly
you're setting up shootouts by allowing
this to happen because if people are
going to exercise their second amendment
rights you have to assume they are going
to have guns in the house and if you
break into someone's house you're going
to get shot at that's what bothers me
about this more than anything else we've
allowed this situation to exist that
makes everyone's house potentially the
okay corral peter
and mike
you know really last night it was very
interesting watching the news my wife
and i watched a lot of news last night
before the football game and there was a
neighbor one of brianna taylor's
neighbors
uh it said that she heard nothing
uh before the door was broken down so
again it's it's basically the police the
police's word that they announced their
presence
uh versus the word of
um
briana taylor's boyfriend who said i
never heard anything
and now there's at least one person who
said i never heard anything either but
be that as it may be that as it may and
be that as you know one shot
hey let me say this there's a lot of
stuff i don't hear when i'm sound asleep
you know that's the other i mean it's
the middle of the night and people are
asleep you can't process information all
you know is somebody's breaking into
your house so
anyway it's but you know the other the
other part of mike is the other the
other part is
listen you know we saw the attorney
general of kentucky the other day stand
up and act outraged that anybody would
question the decision
and i'm just saying to the tv sir there
was one shot fired by one side and 26
shots fired by the other side
you think we sh and somebody died who
had no business dying i mean you think
we shouldn't be
questioning that and and and so look i
don't know we didn't sit in the grand
jury hearings we don't know everything i
get that
but to think that there's not going to
be outrage by the american people and by
very responsible
uh black athletes and white athletes
i think is nonsensical
and here's the reality of grand juries
you know you hear the saying all the
time you can indict a ham sandwich if
you want to and more importantly you
cannot indict
charles manson if you want to it all
comes down to how the prosecutor
presents the case the grand jury
typically follows along whatever the
prosecutor presents because there's no
one else there to offer the other side
to it so if the prosecutor doesn't want
to
have an indictment there's a way to
present the evidence that results in no
indictment and again we don't know what
happened but there's a lot of discretion
both to get someone charged and to not
get someone charged that a prosecutor
possesses what do we think happens this
weekend because when everything went
sideways a month ago after the shooting
of jacob blake russell wilson said hey
if we had a game this weekend we
wouldn't play how do we think this
carries into what we see in week three
i definitely think there's going to be
some amount of demonstration i don't
know what it was what it's going to be
quite honestly i thought one of the nba
games might not get played uh this week
and
and i was a little bit surprised that
both series continued
as normal and i'm not saying they should
or they shouldn't but
i assumed that something was going to
happen there and mike
i don't know whether it's going to be
um some team
not coming out for five minutes or i i
don't have any idea what will happen but
you know i would be surprised if at the
uh 15 games that remain this weekend if
there wasn't something at one of those
games
uh that uh
you know that spoke to the outrage of so
many players around the nfl right now
yeah i agree with you completely and
that was one of the things that that
hovered over the start of the season you
know we worry about covet 19 another
reality is another incident another
video that makes people outraged by what
appears plainly and clearly to be the
use of excessive police force against a
black man or woman that's going to cause
potentially a shutdown of the nfl the
way we saw it in the nba